it's been a labor of love from part one
to part two and three
and um we're just so very proud of
everything that jim has been able to put
together and he weaved a beautiful story
that we just sunk our teeth in and we
just had a lot of fun and i feel like
the weight is finally coming to to a
culmination and we're going to get to
share something that we enjoyed so much
doing our memories of making this movie
together are really fresh because they
involve being underwater and
all kinds of physical prowess especially
on the part of zoe who is such an
amazing warrior still even more so
in this uh in this new one
but i think it's so exciting you know
there was a such a hush and a scream at
the same time kind of if that's possible
watching the 13 minutes and for us
you know
i hadn't seen a lot of it
most of it all of it and uh i think
we were kind of breathless afterward
because we couldn't believe what we saw
yeah we're still processing yeah it
feels really special um
we we believe in this story so much we
believe in the work that jim you know
created for us all
and this was like i said before it was a
labor of love so finally being able to
share it it feels really good i'm still
processing it but my hopes for this
new adventure of avatar
is that we get to give back the first
fans
you know we get to deliver something
really special that they can continue
loving and for our new fans we just we
hope that they are
you know smitten by this sensory
adventure that we're gonna give them jim
showed quite a bit of underwater stuff
uh with the kids and um
it's so magical and of course we were in
a tank where
there's none of that world you have to
make it all up in your head and the
creature is swimming by and everything i
mean
it's just wondrous what he's been able
to accomplish and honestly i don't think
i've ever seen anything like this
in any movie
or certainly in any theater and uh
i think it's just breathtaking
you